Dope. Yeah, that's true. Our whole,
that's just from you. Yeah, that's it.
Even when you were, you were
doing taekwondo, no one gave
you a nickname? No, Joe.
No. When I was a playing pool
a lot, I was Joe the comedian,
GSP with us on the podcast.
He just did on your turning sidekick.
Holy Shit.
Talk about endorses.
Critiquing it as good for a half an
hour has gone on about his power is
incredible. No Shit. George. Holy Shit.
As GSP going off on Joe Rogan. Yeah,
we trained a little afterwards.
I'd say I switched my mats out. I had
those a zebra mats that are super smooth.
No Bueno to slick move
on,
on throwing kicks DVD.
Was it 1997 some sort of a
video will still, you know,
people still John Danaher
just put out a DVD.
Well he put out a video on demand.
I bet he paid
wranglers and fucking under
Armour. Todd's of course, but a DVD
pack game.
Fanny pack.
Uh, yeah, I would, uh, I would
do that. George and I, we,
we went over the front
leg side kick first,
which is like the most important part,
the attorney sidekick.
Once you get the front leg side kick down,
you understand how that works.
Then you turn and then it's basically
you're turning and then throwing the front
leg side kick.
It's just got like an extra push to it,
but most people do the front,
like psychic rom there needs to low and
when it needs to low, you lose all power.
Crazy shit.
If he's going to fight at 55 yeah,
the ones are kind of 55 100%
and he's only 185 pounds.
She has pain 55 and
he's only doing it once.
It's going to be the winner of Conor.
Khabib, he started doing this is see,
look at this. This is what Wonderboy
does. It's CR. That's weird.
That sideways stance is
hard to fuck with man.